we should not attempt to clear our
conscience by arguing that the enemies
of freedom come only from the other from
other cultures and beliefs and that
freedom flourishes and settle it in our
own the scenario ty described above has
had expected corollary of the
reappearance in the Western societies of
racist xenophobic groups and an outbreak
of nationalism that we believed to be
disappearing these are our monsters and
they are not less malignant or dangerous
than the imported ones for democracy to
function a variety of political parties
and movements must exist which represent
the full ideological range of society
naturally it is essential that if not
all at least an undisputable majority of
these political forces share basic
democratic principles in the years
following the two world wars
revolutionary parties existed in free
societies of the right and of the left
which rejected the basic premises of
democracy however they never had enough
electoral support to take power nor was
there any risk it would fall into their
hands in Italy for example where the
Communist Party became very powerful
this parties share certain quarters of
power yet never to the extent of
threatening the system itself after the
fall of the Berlin Wall it seemed
impossible but everything similar would
ever occur again nevertheless the truth
is that today Europe is the scenario of
an unsettling spectacle the re-emergence
of an extremist
nationalistic say no phobic and racist
right which does not believe in
democratic principles and which has made
if rejection of the immigrant and
especially those from Muslim countries
its motto this has been particularly
well received in the population sector
most affected by the economic crisis and
precarious employment these movements
deliver to them the Turk the moon of the
black as the escape gold responsible for
all the country's economic rules for the
rising crime and also of course accusing
them of being potential or current
agents and accomplices of terrorist
groups these political forces which in
the past were no more than mere sects or
a splinter groups are no longer that
today they've had grown increasing their
electoral stock and in many countries
now compete on an equal playing field
with Democratic parties still Wars to
take away these groups voters many
parties of the left and centre have let
themselves become contaminated by these
populist anti-democratic ideologists is
there something that we can't be that
can't be done to confront the monstrance
the monsters return off of Caceres
mobilized against them against them do
not let them advance and do not make
concessions to those who now represent
no more or less than in the past
the negation of all that that has been
done to rise about barbarism to make
societies of the developed world tribe
and become more humane this was made
possible through long struggle seconds
of student
fanaticism prejudice and ignorance as
well as through innumerable conflicts in
which gradually and with the sacrifice
of countless thinkers writers political
leaders union leaders military militant
party members and the common people the
culture of freedom began to take root in
Europe and defeat its enemies
thanks to that lengthly process that
exists open societies human rights
political pluralism freedom of the press
religious freedom gender equality racism
and the rejection of all forms of racial
religious or political discrimination in
known of these areas and for not reason
should governments organizations of
Democratic City seize recant in the list
or take a step backwards because if they
do so they will betray the very
principles of the culture of freedom
this cannot be the sole responsibility
of governments it concerns all citizens
equally it is urgent to address all
initiatives which mask behind pious
pretext such as respect for all cultures
or solidarity with the oppressed attempt
to establish in través communities or
individuals that enjoy extraterritorial
rights accepting accepting them from
obeying the law or rather authorizing
them to break it or to reintroduce in
the political debate any form of racism
and xenophobia regardless of how it is
disguise of how it is disguise
intellectual the media scientists
opinion leaders all those who have
platforms to make themselves heard and
for that very reason know better that
anyone the indispensable nature of
freedom and democracy to guarantee
progress and to ensure that life is
breathable have the civic duty
to take action against the resurgent
monsters and to firmly warn them you
will not prevail